you know Iowa's last game Paulie you
know what happened in Iowa's landscape
football yeah
knowing Iowa football they probably won
in the fourth quarter they won like
think the Holiday Bowl they beat USC in
the Holiday Bowl ended up ten and three
and their head coach Kirk Ferentz joins
us on the program
coach how are you today well I'm doing
well and I appreciate you starting off
what is your time frame for getting your
your athletes back on campus or back
working out right now limbo just waiting
to see what happens and it's going to be
really interesting because you know
things are going to happen differently
across the nation we're already seeing
that but as far as you know bare
minimums I think most of us at least in
the conference agree that at least six
weeks would be preferred and then I'm
hopeful at least maybe two more weeks
with our strength conditioning staff
prior to us being around our guys just
to I think eight weeks would give us a
chance to be you know a decent decent
position for the start of the season
who's gonna make the final decision it
if I looked at just Iowa is it the
governor is it the president of the
university is it gonna be the big ten
when it comes to playing football who
has the final say on what Iowa does with
football I think it's probably you know
the conference's they've been meeting
regularly and I think everybody's on the
same page they're certainly
hopefully we don't get to a scenario
where you know you get into September
and twelve teams can go and maybe two
can't but that's a possibility so I
think they've looked at all those
possibilities that yeah certainly I
think the conference wants to be
together as much as possible like any
any League or any conference but
certainly the the governor the the
president the athletic director all
those people have a prominent role and
at the bottom of the food chain would be
the coaches I think if I said you could
start on time no fans or start six weeks
later with fans what would y'all for
yeah the problem there you know if you
slide the schedule back three four weeks
I think that may be doable although you
have finals in December to contend with
but you know my guess is we probably go
without them
that's just one person's opinion yeah I
don't know does that change how you
coach like so much of college football's
a motion hi guy I don't know you ever
done anything like this yeah and
certainly the players on the field but I
think anybody that if you ever been in
Kinnick Stadium when it when it sold out
and it's rock and it's you know it adds
a lot to the atmosphere conversely when
you go on the road you know it's a big
factor when you play on the road and a
good environment a tough environment so
yeah it's gonna be very sterile if
that's the case and the thing I would
like him ensues when we you know have
usually have a couple scrimmages in the
spring and a couple in preseason camp
we're in your stadium and you're
competing but there's nobody there
outside of the officials they're working
that and the coaches so it's really a
strange feeling quite frankly and you
know the players are still competing but
it doesn't feel the same not well like
we're accustomed to what was your last
contact like with the Big Ten what was
the last update that was actually this
morning we were on a seven o'clock
conference call which they've been 630 I
got it on at 6:30 wonder why nobody was
there what was the update with all the
possible scenarios right now and trying
to plan for other better plan them for
the worst and you know still a lot of
questions be answered just like
everything else that's going on in the
country right now you're talking to Kirk
Ferentz the Iowa head coach I'm
wondering about this though coach
yeah Vanderbilt with the SEC and their
priorities aren't gonna be football like
it would be at other schools they're if
it's northwestern is their priority
going to be football or something else
the fact that certain states are gonna
be a little bit more permissible to
allow you know teams to get together
like it could be an unfair advantage for
some of these teams can can you see
where some schools might be playing and
some schools won't be playing football
in the fall it's like early we're doing
all across the country right now it's
about the people's welfare whether it be
the players the coaches and staff
the fans in the stadium so everybody
involved but yeah I think that is
there's a possibility hopefully it's not
a likelihood but it is a possibility and
that that's where some tough decisions
are really gonna have to get made I
think when it comes to game time and
then in terms of preparation no question
I think some people might have we're
already seeing it where certain states
are opening up a little faster than
others so yeah there are a lot of
factors in play and you know it's just
like like most you know people in my
profession I guess I probably watch more
television and news in the last six
weeks and I have probably the last six
years maybe 16 years so you know you
just share a lot of opinions and I think
bottom line is a lot of us don't really
have answers to a lot of the issues out
there right now are you better
developing tight ends or tackles well
the guys we can't develop as tight ends
[Laughter]
so you got some good tight ends there
coach you got Kittel Fant Hawkinson
Dallas Clark that's pretty good it's
really amazing you know Noah came in or
fat could run like a deer in high school
when he still can they take a guy like
Dallas Clark that was a walk-on
linebacker here he was like our third or
fourth team linebacker back in 2000 or
99 we moved him over so you know it's
it's an interesting thing they all had
different pedigree although they all did
come from different towns and all that
stuff but the bottom line is ended up
being really good players and we're
really proud of all those guys if you
were gonna talk to Tom Brady about his
new tackle tristan worth what would you
tell him he's getting well I think he'll
be really pleased and you know Tristan's
an amazing kid grew up probably about 25
miles from your you know his joke you
know he and AJ up the nest are the kind
of guys we never get where he came with
a really good skill set I actually
played tackle he's the first guy in 21
years to play tackle is a true freshman
for us I think he started seven or eight
games and the best thing about Tristan
right now he's a tremendous person first
and foremost but also his upside he's
only played three years of college
football so the next couple of years not
that Tom Brady cares
Tristan's gonna look like four years
from now but you know the next couple
years he's just I think gonna continue
to blossom he's a really good player and
a tremendous young person were you at
Pitt when Dan Marino was there actually
was yeah so somehow someway we lost a
game in 1980 I was there we were 12 and
one and you know what an unbelievable
player Dan was a tremendous guy
well you had was Hugh Green there as
well yeah so we had Dan was only a soft
jimbo Colvard your green Ricky Jackson
covert Russ Grimm let me go right down
the line there Hall of Famers yeah is my
first exposure to major college football
you probably couldn't tell but I didn't
play is it's you know you're 200 pounds
around a five flat there were not as a
prospect but yeah that was my first
exposure to major college football and
I'm looking around thinking boy this is
pretty this is pretty easy to give up
you guys look like this but there were
great guys and outstanding players how
close did you come to taking the Browns
job in a way you know the answer is now
coach I've always felt like I needed a
compelling reason to to look elsewhere
and the one thing two things about it
you know I came here in 1981 from
Pittsburgh I grew up in Pittsburgh I was
working for my high school coach Joe
Moore who is my you know all-time mentor
in sports so I had an opportunity to
come out here in 1981 think you know I'd
be here one year two years get back to
the East Coast and we stayed here nine
years it was hard for both of us Mary
and I believe then nine years gone and
back here 21 so you know we've always
had a love living here
you loved it as a family and the
professional opportunities been great
so I never felt like I had a compelling
reason belief and the other other sites
but which you know you never never found
on this we've got three of our sons go
through the program so it's really hard
to put a price tag on that it's really
been a valuable and very unique
experience that way plus weren't you Jim
Harbaugh as offensive coordinator does
that were you thinking ball does impose
them
it's marchibroda how is horrible as a
quarterback you have a good staff or you
I'm old I'm right there with you I'm old
I remember we had a meeting actually
about the quarterbacks are available
that you're in the last thing coach
Kotra marchibroda got in from the group
and said just just remember this he goes
you know Jimmy kind of slides by the
seat of his pants and I scratching my
head wondering you know what's that mean
and then when you meet Jim you need to
kind of figure that out real quickly but
he did a great job great leader and then
you get to compete with him yeah it's
it's funny how you hang around long
enough you never know what's gonna
happen so it's been a lot of fun it's
been really interesting well good luck
coach with whatever happens I know
people say it's the new normal it's the
new abnormal because we we have no idea
what's in store but hopefully we get
some college football and we appreciate
your time that's Kirk Ferentz Iowa head
football coach